moi personnellement je pense que
l'oeuvre se doit de représenter le
passage du temps à travers notre société
hyper consumériste et ethnocentrée de
manière à éveiller les consciences de
toute actuelle nous allons parler d'art
messieurs dames aujourd'hui j'ai envie
qu'on parle d'art alors qu'est ce que la
des tableaux des sculptures re des
tableaux j'ai une culture de merde en
barre
écoutez ma curiosité grandit d'année en
année et je me mets à apprécier
certaines formes d'art ce qui me
semblait jusqu'à présent totalement
impossible après attention j'ai
définition de l'art qu'est un peu
abstraite par exemple pour moi quand
j'achète une figurine toys belle
génération que j'ai acheté un objet
d'art
mais qu'est ce que l'art répondre à
cette question qu'est ce que l'art l'art
c'est par exemple quand vous tapez art
contemporain sur google cette
merveilleuse culture de pied en bronze à
48 euros
et ça c'est précisément ce que j'adore
avec l'art c'est que ça regroupe plein
de création de plein de gens et qu'il ya
un truc qui est totalement subjectif
c'est vraiment un milieu où une même
pièce une meuf quelqu'un va la trouver
genre excellente de malades c'est la
plus belle qu'il ait vu de sa vie est
quelqu'un d'autre c'est la pire qu'ils
aient vu de sa reflète vraiment la
sensibilité de chacun et ça me fait
beaucoup rire
en vrai c'est vachement intéressant on
commence avec des trucs pas trop floue
mais par exemple il y à cette personne
qui fait des portraits avec un fil
il a un fils et il te fait harry potter
regardez comme c'est un selon lequel a
juste une bobine de fil des clous un
truc pour mesurer une pince il a il a ce
qu'on va toucher nous on a tout ça chez
nous regardez vue de profil c'est beau
tous ses fils
et quand on recule au juge unique est
pour moi par exemple je pourrais aussi
vous montrer ce mec qui fait lui aussi
des portraits en brisant du verre
regardez ça c'est un peu bizarre vu
comme ça ça me fait mal au coeur de
péter du verre mais regardez ne voyez
vous pas le visage sur ce verre n'avez
vous pas envie d'avoir une fenêtre
portrait finalement je suis sûr que si
alors vous connaissez probablement
quelques artistes qui font de l'art qui
sont très connus on va pas regarder ça
aujourd'hui nous allons parler de l'art
insoupçonnées on va regarder des trucs
qui sont dollars qui sont des oeuvres
d'art mais vous comme moi on savait pas
que ça existait je veux dire qu'ils
suspectaient qu'un pied en bronze
pouvait coûter réduit milot et moi un
plaid en 2020 excuses nous gros artistes
en tous cas on peut pas mieux résumer le
confinement qu'avec cette image se fait
tellement fier à force de faire des
fixettes chine qui dessine une montagne
sur son plein c'est bon pour vous une
sculpture faite à l'aide de nombreux
crayon de papier c'est très fort c'est
très fort et ça c'est un truc qui font
rager ces trucs qu'on a tous chez nous
mais on n'a pas le savoir faire on a les
crayons mais pas nous
faire un la sculpture de gori ça les
gars je crois une grenouille fait à
partir de détritus
le mec est tellement créatif qu'au
moment de fermer son sac poubelle il se
dit et le bout de tissu mais en faire
une gros dos il a alors ça cette oeuvre
la chaleur et sochi le meds d'une vente
aux enchères aujourd'hui c'est la
fameuse sphères où le mec qu'a pas un
truc à 360° dessus et ça crée un petit
effet mind fuck c'est très sympa je
l'achète pas ok ça c'est les trucs de
perspective où ces genres un bordel
d'objets et quand tu te mets dans un axe
précis
voilà [ __ ] ça m'énerve ça forme un
visage en l'occurrence moi je me dire
quand c'est le bordel chez moi peu
importe là que s'il n'y a pas trop de
visages qui a parlé ça reste un tas
d'ordure quoi mais vous avez déjà vu sa
passe et j'en suis sûr et l'effet est
vraiment cool
c'est un très bel effet comme cet effet
de montage là c'est un très bel effet ça
allez ça c'est encore un truc issus du
confinement c'est sûr en vrai le dessin
est très sympa moins impressionnant
qu'une montagne je trouve attention
c'est très sérieux là on émet des avis
très précieux alors qu'on n'a aucune
crédibilité là dedans c'est pas grave
ces principes d'internet hockey en
revanche ce coussin les gars je vous dis
la vérité j'en ai un coussin avec la
vous savez la matière perlé yassa sur
des vêtements aussi sur des vêtements
pas de souci c'est mignon et tout mais
mettent ça sur une matière qui sans
cette genre douce et rembourré et lahi
les gens rugueux voire même coupant
quand le truc est un peu levé excusez
moi mais c'est non aussi un dessin qu'il
a fait seulement en froissant le papier
pour donner du volume et de la
perspective c'est très fort holmes
quelques cachets oui c'est clair c'est
totalement postmoderne
cwi une chaise qui a grandi sur un arbre
à ho chi l'ha hilali mais le tronc et il
est allé au ikea le plus proche acheter
des planches et des vis pour former une
chaise voilà ça va me plaire de ouf
[Musique]
vois tu rien fait pour moi mec c'est
incroyable le gars il a un doctorat en
ingénierie spécialisation robotique
il peut bosser chez ceux qui font les
chiens là où ils les font danser sur des
musiques mignonne là pour faire genre
qu'ils sont mignons alors qu'ils nous
tenions bus tous lui non non non il a
compris que la robotique avait recruté
grippe il gens venir dans mon bureau le
des humains il cligne de l'oeil aux
essais genre des sorts de brûlures grain
de beauté
les chiffres aux théories c'est trop
bien fait mais tu peux vraiment jouer
avec ça c'est vraiment impressionnant
chez dans le cinéma il utilise beaucoup
cette matière là pour faire des doubles
des acteurs pour certaines scènes et
tout mais eux ils l'utilisent pour faire
genre dé rendre vivant des objets quoi
c'est creepy mais j'adore les gages ou
alors lui il a fait ou attention
beaucoup de vue et que ça fait autant de
vue c'est dollars à bakou en fait lui il
a fait un miroir qui reproduit ces
mouvements grâce à
kinect une kinect dernière fois que j'en
ai vu une c'était quand on a fait cette
vidéo sur cyprien gamming qu'est ce que
c'est que ce bordel c'est des moteurs
qui font se déplacer des boules beige et
noir et les boules noires reproduisent
le mouvement que tu fais devant la
kinect aussi étonnant que cela puisse
être l'effet est très réussi on dirait
le masque de dans watchmen
comment il s'appelle le perso qui a le
masque sa bouche dedans rorschach c'est
le masque de rorschach ça y est ça m'est
parvenu j'ai dû aller sur google
j'ai la haine quoi ça c'est de la
sculpture dans une pastèque mais quelle
insolence on le fait exploser tous les
posteurs us culte des pieuvres réaliste
c'est marrant la sculpture quand vous ai
plein d'activités manuelles c'est un
truc qu'on avait mis sur le tapis avec
lorraine on n'avait jamais failli le
faire et en fait c'est tellement
technique est tellement longue qu'on
l'avait pas fait en gros j'aurais juste
plus sculptée à mener c'est tout c'est
nul
oh c'est ouf j'avais oublié ça le body
paint c'était tellement à la mode un
moment vous souvenez opa sur un style
tout y avait trop de gens qui faisait du
body paint là on est sur une artiste qui
a eu l'idée
[ __ ] c'est vraiment fort de body paint
et un mec mais de le mettre dans un
décor qu'elle a aussi peint et du coup
en joignant la peinture du décor et le
body paint de dugas on dirait qu'il
s'agit d'une seule et unique of dans
lequel il ya personne quoi on se rend
plus compte que c'est un vrai mec qui
est là assis c'est vraiment fort ça me
donne envie de me faire peindre concours
de regards quoi ils organisent des
battles bizarre et c'est stressant vrai
c'est un v1 entre un ventilateur équipé
d'un couteau et un ballon le ventilateur
par définition vue qui pousse le ballon
il pourra jamais l'atteindre avec son
couteau
le tout étant donc devenu de la st pal
idée rigolote j'aime bien j'aime
beaucoup
une sculpture en papier qui ressemble à
une statue
quoi quoi quoi quoi
assez des livres à l'intérieur waouh
qu'est incroyable là on voit avant que
ce soit pas mais [ __ ] quand c'est pain
c'est tellement bien fait c'est hyper
man fac
franchement je n'avais pas du tout
compris ce que c'était c'est trop
bizarre on dirait dehors de chewing gum
étrange c'est trop cool soit juste des
livres en fait je pensais que ces deux
matières hyper chimiques mais pas du
tout ça c'est connu et c'est incroyable
c'est comme le maillot tout à l'heure
c'est des mecs au moment de sortir leurs
poubelles chez parisien passe mal au
coeur ils font une oeuvre d'art on est
sur un vrai tas d'ordures dans l'ombre
forme une scène tout autre c'est un
binôme c'est tim noble et suez webster
et je crois que c'est leur spécialité 1
je crois qu'ils font que ça ça doit puer
dans l'expo je suis dit c'est la seule
remarque que j'ai à faire sur eux c'est
tellement honteux serra sont de vrais
rats
mec c'est dur on te tu entends pas et
puis on veut faire croire que tu es
pikachu c'est embêtant quand même
cette oeuvre est bannie de l'exposition
je sais je suis navré je suis navré ça
c'est non pour moi genre pourquoi tu
avais besoin de prendre des rats en
paille et si c'est pour les peindre en
jaune fait défaut à quand tu vas mourir
je vais te peindre en jaune moi aussi et
de mètres au milieu d'un faux shibuya
pourquoi j'ai beaucoup d'empathie pour
serra je ne sais pas je ne sais pas
pourquoi ça les gars on est tous un peu
sensible à saint amand au jeu de lumière
qui forme des belles choses non je
mettrai ça au dessus du berceau de mon
enfant ça deviendra un grand artiste
une voiture obèses jelade hors jeu
l'adorent premier degré elle est trop
bien gérée pas qu'elle est obèse moi
j'ai juste qu'elle a une forme de
plastique qui coule quoi vous êtes dur
avec cette voiture
elle est trop bien je la veux la belle
et la bête
quoi voit même moi qui adore le crépi là
c'est trop elle m'a fait plus mal
derrière la même moi qui adore le crépi
là c'est peut-être un peu trop les gars
j'aime bien j'aime pas chez pas en tout
cas je chute pas qu'est ce que c'est que
ça non mais arrêtez
qu'est ce que c'est que ça met au les
ruches d'abeilles il faut pas les mettre
sur sa tête mais qu'un je comprends rien
là c'est ça c'est de l'art là c'est de
là qu'on voit mais qu'est ce qu'on vient
de voir en fait exactement
les gens ont beaucoup trop de temps
libre je suis un peu d'accord la lega
jeu
i'm out c'est une sculpture intéressante
qu'on a là whaou incroyable s'est fait à
partir de poupée
c'est ignoble j'adore le socle là avec
toutes les têtes c'est terrible au cmec
oui ça y est ce qu avait pas mais
l'image d'avoir maintenant quitté la
vidéo mec c'est juste un gars il est
trop fan de monsieur patate et s'est dit
mais pourquoi je me limiterai à jour un
kit de monsieur patate je vais acheter
45 poupées et je me servir des membres
des 45 pour fermer construction c'est
excellent what what fascinant et
terrifiant et terrifiant au lait c'est
bon j'ai ma dose en face qui écrit puis
c'est qu'on dirait que c'est un humain
qui est accroupi et qui fait ça mais en
fait il ya trois bras et c'est des
robots g c'est ça mais mal chapeau
l'artiste
alors ça c'est des dessins avec des
bactéries
mais les gars vous voulez pas genre
acheter le petit pack de feutre là comme
tout le monde à leclerc ou pourquoi
pouvoir pourquoi vous allez chercher des
bactéries pour dessiner et vous avez
craqué l'aube stop
messieurs dames alors est ce que vous
avez apprécié là franchement même si
j'approuve absolument pas tout je suis
toujours fasciné par voir ce qui est des
gens ont créé quoi on est tous sensibles
à quelque chose et peut-être qu'il
n'avait pas encore trouvé le type
d'oeuvre auquel vous êtes sensibles et
ça viendra j'ai aucun doute en plus moi
j'ai la chance d'être de bien vivre quoi
donc je peux faire des commandes à des
artistes des petits artistes et ça fait
trop plaisir d'acheter un truc que tu
trouve cool et puis d'envoi de la force
artistes parce que c'est quand même pas
facile comme métier et puis là j'ai
découvert un peu le délire du verre des
gens qui ce qui souffle du verrou qui
sculptent du verbe à une personne
s'apaisent et bibi j'ai acheté une
petite à un petit chiba et je suis trop
content d'avoir acheté ça j'en suis trop
fier de malade j'ai pas j'adore je suis
content bref c'est mon délire du moment
donc je voulais en parler à bientôt
portez vous bien vous n'oublierez pas
évidemment les visages là qui tirent la
langue
ça va rester en tête de trois jours
c'est normal vous au plaisir à bientôt
les petits quizz hausse
[Musique]